better rights on the horizon for air
passengers the industry says 800 million
passengers flew in europe in 2011 not
counting transit a figure that all
except will continue to rise but what
when things go wrong cancellations
damaged or lost luggage late boarding
meps have just agreed a new charter of
rights that include better compensation
reimbursement and information
the rights of lesbian bisexual gay
transgender and intersex people may be
gradually improving on europe's statute
books but on the ground people in these
groups say they continue to be attacked
and discriminated against parliament
says it's time to make sure fundamental
rights are respected and wants a roadmap
outlining objectives in among many
fields healthcare employment families
and free movement and education like for
example what do you write in teaching
materials about the fact that lesbians
and gays bisexual transgender people
exist in every society in every school
in every ministry in every sports
organization that's one thing and the
other thing is capacity building in
police
many lgbt people when they are harassed
or even attacked violently are afraid to
go to the police because they're afraid
to be discriminated a second time
greenland a danish territory that's in
the eu's list of overseas countries and
territories was cleared to join the
kimberley process a certification scheme
in which governments industry and civil
society cooperate to stem the flow of
conflict diamonds greenland is
experiencing a diamond rush because of
the melting ice cap exposing
diamond-bearing rock hidden from
millennia